With its ever-expanding selection of films,
Netflix has plenty of psychological thrillers
that are perfect for movie night.
But it's time to look beyond popular films
like Bird Box and No Country for Old Men.
Here are a few disturbing films you probably
haven't seen ... but don't watch them alone!
In The Good Neighbor, we immediately learn
that the supposed haunting of Harold Grainey
— played by James Caan — has been orchestrated
by his two tech-savvy teenage neighbors, Sean
and Ethan.
But that doesn't make the situation any less
terrifying.
"With the proper execution, it is possible
to drive an unsuspecting person into believing
that they are truly being haunted."
Sean has his reservations about the whole
scheme, but Ethan is clearly on a mission.
For this guy, getting the reclusive old man
to believe he's being haunted is more than
just a prank.
The reason he's tormenting Grainey is far
darker than that… and the consequences turn
out to be deadly.
Grainey handles the strange occurrences in
his home surprisingly well… until Ethan
escalates his efforts and pushes him over
the brink.
This interesting take on the found-footage
genre serves as a warning about the many pitfalls
of revenge.
"Is he looking at us?
He knows!"
Simply put, The Good Neighbor is one of the
most intense thrillers Netflix has to offer
right now.
Brick might not be as well known as Joseph
Gordon-Levitt's other films, but there's a
reason it's become a cult favorite.
In this twisty mystery, Gordon-Levitt portrays
Brendan Frye, a lonely teenager who recently
went through a breakup with his ex-girlfriend,
Emily — played by Emilie de Ravin of Lost
fame.
When Brendan finds a note directing him to
a pay phone, he's already in way over his
head.
Emily winds up dead, and Brendan starts working
his way through a mystery that involves a
musclebound bully, a high school drug kingpin,
and a few seemingly random words that serve
as cryptic clues to Emily's fate.
Needless to say, it's all very hardboiled.
"1250, Vista Blanca, the ink blotter on the
desk, in the den, in the basement of the house
with the tacky mailbox."
Directed by Rian Johnson, Brick pays homage
to classic detective films, but the plot and
characters are still distinctly modern.
Although Gordon-Levitt has certainly appeared
in bigger blockbusters, it'd be a real shame
to overlook Brick.
With its clever plotting, rapid-fire dialogue,
and sly references to film noir classics,
this psychological thriller is definitely
worth investigating.
What's scarier than suddenly discovering there's
an uninvited guest in your house?
We've seen this plot play out in horror films
a million times before… but we've never
seen a film approach the premise the way that
Hush does.
Kate Siegel plays Maddie, a deaf-mute woman
who lost her ability to hear and speak as
a teenager.
These days, she lives alone in an isolated
cabin in the woods.
However, her quiet life takes a turn for the
terrifying when a masked intruder begins to
prey upon her.
When he realizes Maddie can't hear, the psychopath
uses his newfound knowledge to torment his
new victim... and what follows is a fiendish
game of cat-and-mouse that simply won't let
up.
Hush is a serious nail-biter that's decidedly
not for the faint of heart.
The found-footage film Creep is indeed a full-fledged
creepshow — and it comes highly recommended.
The story begins innocently enough for our
protagonist Aaron.
The videographer is heading out to meet a
new client named Josef, who wants to create
a series of videos for his unborn son.
Josef tells Aaron that he's dying of cancer,
but he wants his son to have a way of getting
to know his father.
But as Josef's behavior becomes stranger and
more concerning, Aaron has a strong urge to
flee.
After all, Josef's stories aren't adding up,
and Aaron is worried for his own safety.
But Josef is determined to keep tabs on Aaron,
and when the videographer runs, he quickly
discovers that he can't really hide from this
full-fledged psycho.
"Are you gonna let me go?"
And if you're looking for a truly chilling
"Netflix and chill" experience, you're in
luck.
In 2017, the sequel Creep 2 was released,
and it's also streaming on Netflix.
Double the derangement!
In Backtrack, Adrien Brody plays Peter Brower,
a psychotherapist who's starting to realize
there's something strange about his clients.
Like, seriously strange.
Meanwhile, Peter is suffering recurring nightmares
and depressive episodes due to the death of
his daughter.
Eventually, he comes to a somewhat startling
revelation: All of his clients are dead.
If only he'd picked up on the subtle signs
sooner...
Peter begins to research who his clients were
when they were alive, and eventually discovers
they all lived near a specific train line
— one that happened to regularly pass right
through his hometown.
Now, Peter must retrace his steps by going
back home, seeking out some familiar faces,
and trying to understand why he's at the center
of a haunting.
Backtrack is a journey through Peter's murky
memory as he struggles to figure out how to
make things right between his past and his
present.
This psychological thriller serves as a strong
reminder that Adrien Brody is a singular talent
— and he turns in an absolutely fantastic
performance here.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
thrillers are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.